welcome back to cbs this morning we have
a story that hits close to home for us
here at cbs news about strangers who are
now forever connected
you know 13 people die every day in the
u.s waiting for a kidney to be
transplanted
about 100 000 americans are on a waiting
list and one of them
is our cbs news colleague mark winer now
i want to be fully transparent about how
this story came to be
many of us saw a post on our we are cbs
news instagram account
and it showed mark and his picture in
times square
asking for someone to help him and we
thought well what what's going on we
didn't know mark
needs a kidney turns out there's an nypd
detective who had already tried to save
mark's life
mark weiner is so desperate to find a
kidney that he's making his plea to the
world
at the crossroads of the world on a big
old billboard
how bad do you want this i want it bad
um
i don't want to sound selfish but
i want to be healthier i want to be able
to do
things with my family and not be limited
after being diagnosed with bladder
cancer in 2015
at the age of 50 weiner underwent
surgery to remove his bladder
his prostate and both kidneys he is now
cancer-free
but he needs dialysis three days a week
i'm very fortunate
but dialysis can be an extremely
debilitating
event weiner began his public quest in
2018
when a company first donated ad space in
times square
nypd detective michael lalo saw that
billboard and he felt like he had to do
something
that's just something that touched me i
can't quite quantify it
despite being total strangers detective
lalo got tested to give his kidney to
weiner
but he wasn't a match still though he
decided to donate his organ
to save another stranger
kindness is contagious and i would
urge people to look into being a living
kidney donor
and to look into being a donor now
while you're alive now retired from the
nypd
lalo is an advocate for kidney donation
david i don't know if you have two
kidneys but if you do i'm sitting here
saying why there are about 99 000 and
change people today
that need a kidney there's so many
diseases out there that there is no cure
there's a cure you could donate
a kidney to somebody through a voucher
program winer could receive the
life-saving kidney transplant
even if the donor is not a direct match
he just needs someone to donate a kidney
on his behalf
that way he can be entered into the
national kidney registry
which will then search for his perfect
match
all mark needs is basically a partner to
go
into the national kidney registry and
whoever is seeing this broadcast is not
just going to save mark's life
they're going to save at least one other
person because you're going to be
creating
a chain they were strangers connected
through that selfless act
that keeps on giving but if you are in
the spirit of giving
think about giving your kidney you're
going to save a life
and ultimately who knows you may be
helping me out we are rooting for our
buddy mark weiner i i
we're so inspired by his story and i
have to tell you working with mark for
the last several years watching him walk
into the building
you would never know not waking up at 5
00 a.m to go to dialysis ending at 9 a.m
and coming to work three times a week
so david just explain to the viewers you
just have to sign up for this registry
that's right
and you can save somebody's that's right
and if you don't match with mark
you can match with someone else right so
the the beauty here is you pay it
forward to someone
hopefully mark but if you can't help
mark you'll help someone and finally
that circle of life
will hit mark i love it love it so if
you want to donate let me give you the
website
kidney registry.org real easy kidney
registry.org